if you had to start over and build a
production company from scratch with the
knowledge that you have now how would
you do
it how would I do it um let's from a
strategic standpoint or from a task
standpoint okay both CU I like how you
you're you're you're you're designating
these two it's good both from a strategy
standpoint I would definitely make sure
that you you are compl really
clear what the outcome is going to
be like you want to know what you're
trying to get to and this that Clarity
is so important because that's uh that's
how you create your decision makings
from the start and that's how you know
how to troubleshoot and figure things
out because that part is so
clear before I wasn't so clear about it
before I was just knew that I wanted to
just impact and that's just just a loose
term but you know if the more you
actually narrow down to what that I
wouldn't say it's like an end goal but
almost something that almost feels
impossible to achieve but you know that
that's what you want to see before
you're
dead that's what you need to figure out
right from the beginning of when you
make when you make the company because
you have to think about why do you want
to exist do you need does do you does
the world need another company does the
world need another filmmaker does the
world need another production company
why do you want to compete if you want
to make money going into a different
industry you know what I'm saying
there's plenty of places that make money
that can't be the goal so why are you
going to production because you love it
that much why do you love that why do
you love production so much that part
has to be really clear and it surprised
to me that so many people are not clear
they just like to do it just to like to
do it but they they're going to go into
this Vanilla Ice pattern Van Ice has
this number one hip-hop and everything
El but never clear clear with and it
went through a depression people would
go through that depression mode if
you're not clear where you're at you
know with your business and your
business will more than likely
falter you know the ones that are really
clear with that business from my
experience from what I seen are the ones
that actually could sustain the business
for a long time I've had that business
for 18 years you know and I built
multiple businesses that's over 10 years
now and I did it without social media
zero social media so so it was about
Clarity and it was about um you know
luckily I came to be clear about it when
I was in 2012 2011 2012 when I was clear
about it going back to the Vanilla Ice
Theory I love this Theory so so Vanilla
Ice hit song back in early 90s I think
okay and then we didn't hear from him
for a while and then he got into BMX
biking I think did didn't he that's
right okay to so he so he was always in
biking he went back into it to because
he was going through a depression and he
went back into that because he that in
that world nobody was judging him okay
in the music world people were judging
he was tell this he would told the story
to us that you know he would run this
party and they would drop a $5,000 vase
and be like oh my bad man sorry and you
know he realizes something like that
like nobody really cared about him and
that's when he said that his weekend
last for 3 years and so um he revived
himself by going to the biking world and
where he you know enjoyed and loved and
the people around never judged him for
for that and it kind of tells the story
of that community and belonging really
matters how much experience did you have
when you started a production
company I was 19 when I started my first
production company the music production
company
um and it failed and I started a second
one with another partner and that failed
and so in 2005 I started another one and
I started in the production and
technology company and and it almost
failed but what I did was I I um I just
kept the name and I left it for seven
years like I just kind of just had the
company name and people do that uh until
I could figure out how to build a
business the only one that actually
succeeded was is the uh K vibe in 2005
and um and that was from my experiences
from failing the previous production
companies so it wasn't just timing or
luck or anything it was because you
learned all the things not to do you had
the strategies yeah or and you knew the
tasks yeah I KN I I certainly knew how
to start a
company I certainly knew and and every
time I did it I always had to figure out
how to build this business plan and this
long business plan of 30 to 50 P does
not work for me it's just I just not
that type of guy so what I did was I I
built another way of doing it and I did
it in boxes like a storyboard and my and
my business plan was all in storyboards
when you look at it it's like an or
chart so my strategies are all built
like that and all my tasks are built
like like boards so I don't build my
story boards in Pages anymore and so
that I learned that and that helped me
tremendously so I would say like you
know to anyone is trying to start the
business or trying to start that where
it is you got to find your own template
that works for you everyone the template
that that that standard didn't work for
me at all if anything it caused more
headaches for
me so so aside from from the template um
there were other things it seems like
that you knew either don't do this it's
a waste of time do more of this for 100%
but not not just that you know what it
is I think the I put myself in a place
to learn other people's
mistakes and I asked a lot of questions
tons of questions like a documentary
filmmaker would do
and um I mean there's nothing like going
through it
yourself but going through the mistakes
that they go through and being terrified
with with what they went
through is enough for you to Pivot your
business to a place that could be very
successful what do you think the core
Essentials are for starting a production
company the core Essentials would be
your
purpose you got to have a purpose number
one like you know it cannot be about
money that's number two those are those
are rules for me um
and it's got to be impactful it's got to
help something it's got to solve a
problem those are the three cores um
after that it's our it's like you know
obviously your integrity all the
standard stuff that makes a good human
being right are Essentials to building a
to to the business but the people that
the the most important things is
understanding your your positioning your
POS your your purpose and knowing that
that um that you are solving a problem
filmmakers relating you about to
filmmakers films have to solve a problem
you're solving a problem whether you in
comedy you doing in a horror format or
you're doing a dramedy whatever it is
format you're telling a story that's
solving something that that that was
that's going to help
somebody how much money does it cost to
start a production company
zero doesn't cost anything maybe okay
$125 to
incorporate depending on what state
you're in you know you got EIN number if
you're in New Jersey EI number and those
I mean cost you less than $200
started um the started production
company you know I mean nowadays you
have a phone you could start anything
it's it's
um I started with nothing I started
actually I started with the
DSLR with a DSL with a lens and 85 mm
lens and that's all I had and a in
a weak
tripod did it fall sometimes yeah week
it did it did and it it was like it
wasn't with a fluid it was like those
photography tripods you know and you
can't even really pan with it that was
my that was my first you know and it was
with the Canon it was the Canon 5D Mark
I where you have to half the lens so you
get 20 so you get like 24 frames out of
it you couldn't do 24 frames out of it
if you because it was the bug you you
had to work with that was my first uh
first uh experience in
production and how did you get to these
weddings what was your how did you end
up getting your first wedding um so my
because I'm in the music industry uh my
friend is the um the DJ for DJ Valentino
he was the DJ for 103.5 for New York uh
New York radio station and he had his
own side gig which is weddings and he
had told
meqa look I'm in the weddings because
and they will never go away I will
always have a business
and said would you like to do one
because one of my videographers left and
I said no way I'm going to do this you
know I'm not going to do weddings that's
that was my thing he goes I'll pay you
$750 all right deal let's do
it I said really and then he goes sure
and then for one day gig right so I did
it and then I just saw how ludicrous
that industry was just an
insane like how is this how does this
thing even function and and uh that's
how I got into it and I saw a problem
and I went to solve it do you think when
you're starting a production company
someone should focus on getting the
right equipment or getting the right
people to work for
them you have
to neither none
both you have to be again you have to be
in the right mindset it's the the first
portion of it because if you're not
you're not going to get the right people
to work with
you and if you focus on equipment then
uh but then you didn't build it you you
you didn't build a structure to
understand how to tell stories or what
it is then the equipment goes useless
this I know tons of equipment
collectors I call them they got millions
of dollar of equipment they got all this
and they can't even do anything with it
because they don't know how to do use it
I know tons of those Ty of people and so
it's so that that's not going to create
any success and I know people that know
tons of people that don't know how to
deploy them because they can't get a you
know they can't use them for
anything right and so it starts with you
it starts with you understanding how to
execute and create initiatives and
having a purpose to doing that it has to
be that way there's no other way of
doing it what habits do you use every
day for running your companies my
day-to-day habits work related wise
would be that I go through my emails in
the
morning and I don't check them I only
check two three times a day that's all I
do I don't sit on my
emails um get rid of all the micro small
tasks in the morning before lunch and
then all the creative stuff goes after
lunch as much as I can um and then if I
can't get it if I can't finish it um I
work to I got two kids after I put them
to sleep I work to 3 4:00 in the morning
to wrap them up and then I rinse and
repeat again so all the micro and
mundane and writing invoices and just
business stuff um that goes in the
beginning and that's really important
because you can't get that part done it
just they start stacking up on you so an
unfinished task weighs you down um yeah
it annoys me it's like a it's like a
monkey on your back it just can't get
rid of so just so what I do oh yeah
another one is I use the the Apple
reminder and I just list them up now
another thing is I always put the
reminders in my
calendar and under one thing so every
time open my calendar I see it I always
have to click on it to see all the
task that's how I do it too what are
your final thoughts to anyone thinking
of starting a production
company my final
thoughts
thoughts again it go I don't want to
repeat myself but it it is just make
sure you're starting with a purpose that
you're solving something that someone
else cannot do you know or solving
something that that there's a need for
don't just start one because you're just
starting one and I would say it's um if
you're going to start one do it right
you know um make sure that you're
make sure that you're you're going to
try your best to run a proper business
not a business that's going to hurt
people because some people what I think
one of the mistakes is that these
artists or these filmmakers they start a
production company but they don't have I
want to say they don't have integrity
but they don't
understand the business
ethics you know paying people on time
all those things doing contracts
properly uh nickel and diming you know
working with trustworthy people
onboarding people not taking advantage
or employees or
contractors those are things that are
really important if you're going to do
it then do it right you know um because
if you do it right and and pay you taxes
right if you do it right then it's going
to then you have you'll have a
sustainable business and that people are
going to want then you're then you're
doing something that a lot of people
that don't do it right and then you're
solving that part of the problem too and
when you talk about the why um this
isn't just like a mission statement this
is like a personal why that maybe you
don't even put in your business plan or
on your website this is your personal
sort of reason that you don't really
even need the world to know but you know
that's driving
you um my thoughts around
that you know what it's just you know
what it's my upbringing at the end of
the day right I think you have to know
you have to go
back you have to go back
to your
core um your core feelings of why you
want
to be in a space
that's that's has a lot that's difficult
you have to know that if you don't then
why be in it if you're being you know
like I want people to just know that you
know your personal why is core to your
business they're not separate personal
and business is very personal that's how
I look at it I I see a lot of
entrepreneurs and they're you know very
successful ones too and they separate
emotions to their business and they try
to teach that but that does for me that
doesn't work and so my my thing is that
you know you're especially in today's
age that work is it's 247 your personal
life is 24/7 you're integrating in the
film making world it's not a 95 job
right so you I think you have to have a
strong personal um connection
to why are you in a business or in an
industry
that why are you in this industry that
is is you I mean I think you have to be
able to answer that question why you're
in this industry at the end of the day
and I I I don't know I mean I I think
it's um I think your personal I think
your personal why is extremely important
that you have to tie into your business
this it's not it's not it's not I don't
think it's it's an option has anyone
ever said to you quad it's not fair like
you do everything it makes it look so
easy you're effortless you you know
computers you know music you know this
it's not fair like you just everything
you do you can just you you understand
this this grasp of it I've been out of
this many years and I can't do
this how how are you doing
this yeah I get I get that question a
lot too um and you're
young it's not
fair um you know what I mean i' I've I I
feel like you you know that's why I call
I call it gifts right I call it that it
was a you know it was it's a capability
that I have that I'm able to absorb um
skills skills quickly and and be able to
manifest them into something that is
that could work from for my career sure
um but it was also sheer hard work and I
think people need to know that I don't
know anyone that works harder than
me you know like I see them on TV but I
never met them in real life and I never
went head to-head but I know amongst all
my friends they had they had their fun
times and drinking playing whatever
they're doing and I remember myself
crying saying that I just can't get this
thing done you know I'm I've done it for
20 plus years I look young I'm 42 years
old you know I look young but I started
when I was 19 years old
working four or five four 4 to 5:00 I
don't remember giving an 8 hour
sleep just think about it I came here
red
ey right 9:45 took me an hour and a half
to get the car to come over here I don't
have my airnbb I'm outside putting my my
shirt on you know you know get my lunch
at 12:00 I'm timing myself minute to
minute to get here on time to be
respectful of your time thank you and
I'm I'm wired as if I drank like 10
bottles of Coke still you know you know
what I'm saying you
know I don't know anyone that's willing
to do that and I'll fly out tomorrow
because I because time is precious for
me and so I didn't want to be here to
hang out I wanted to get here I wanted
to do your um I wanted to be in front of
your camera and add value to your
audience you know and add value to the
community and and that was a very
strategic purpose for wanting to be here
with you you know and I think it's very
important for me to you know to be
privileged to be on your platform to uh
to be able to speak out loud about how I
feel about it that's worthy of coming
out and doing all that to do that you
know and so so it goes back down to it
goes back to how much do you want it if
you really really want it you're G to
figure out how to do it and you'll be
I don't want to be like me you going do
it your way might even doing better than
me thank you it's a privilege to have
you